e
herkese merhaba
evlendireceğiz renkli telefon geçmişte
[Müzik]
yaşadığımız ve
bu birinci benzer şekilde yaşamış
görmekten halihazırda olanın endemik
olduğu salgın devam ettiği ülkelerle su
ve güvenlik kısmına olmuş
aynıdır bu
yani yarattığı değil bu insan 56
İnsanoğlu gelişmiş dünya ölçüde bu
coğrafyada şunu güvenliklerini sağlasın
ya da sağlayabilir size olayla karşı
karşıya kalacağız Kore Paraya Bağlı
göremezsiniz en önemli gördüm şundan
önemli böyle Aslında 17-18 yüzünü asılı
İnşallah Eğer w20105 saat daha da genel
anlamda baktığımızda
[Müzik]
da İnsanoğlu da
abone ol
bu
soğan hiç bölüm oraya bağlı ölümlerde
gördüm
[Müzik]
aynısı gelişmesiyle
geçmiyor Ondan sonra
Amerikan gençlik
dahi geçmedi
yaşananlardan alıp şiirler vefa şiirleri
dışına yaşamaları kaçmaya başlayınca
etkenler ile karşılaşmaya başladım yani
bildiğimiz bilmediğimiz içecek olarak
görmekte
farklı mı
[Müzik]
ve gerçekten aşınmıştır buraya gelmiştim
bu dünya model geçtiğimiz zaman için
görüşleri yer her attığı
görüşler var ya az önce buraya geldim
Aşağıda konuştum ülkesinde
yaşanan savaş
ne oluyor yeni etkenlerden o
[Müzik]
bu ne yapıyoruz geçmişte deneyimleyerek
modeliyle görüşüyorlar
kullanmak gerekiyor yazı tarihçesi
Dişlere bak
[Müzik]
şu anda yaşadığımız Allah'u salgını
benzeri etkileyen sağlar tarih boyunca
görmüş bazı Barış olmuş ağzınızı şimdi
duruyor insanlar insanlar devam olmuş
bitmiş bazı yerler devam ediyor bazı
haline gelmiş bazı olarak da malzeme
haline git malzeme almış gelen salgılar
İnsanoğlu bütün organizmalar bir
baktığınızda yaşamaya kodlu Ben öyle bir
süreci dediğimiz sürecin başladığını
göreceksiniz de orada kalacağım
arkadaşını dans ettiği şarkı söyle
kusura bakma biraz daha
devam etmek istiyoruz Yani şimdi ben
dinlemekten arkadaşımla konuşuyorum Ay
yıldızı al
resim gösterme
devam ediyor Şimdi öldürücü geldi
görüyorsunuz hikaye alıyor ve yardım
kalın
değil mi
[Müzik]
ve
onların iki buçuk adı ölüm sayısı
oluşturup olmuş Market
bu
bölümü Ekrem
yapalım tartışılıyor ya
Şekerci ölüm sayısı bu değil aslında bağ
olur bağırma geldi verdiğimiz bir
kavrama nasıl yumurta
açma
şunu yapıyorum Aslında amaçsız olarak
bir dünya kursun
olduğuna göre bilinen ve önceliklerine
bağlı olarak kadınların kaydı ile
Aslında her yeni
yıla gireceğiz yeni
olacak aynı mı
[Müzik]
Ne
olmuş yani Aslında ne yapmalı da çok
Yıldızı bilgiler olduğunu
düşünerek bir tanesi bu Türkiye'den bir
ip hepinizin yapmıyoruz istemiş izinizin
yapmalıyız O bize gerçek
bir tanesi bütün dünya kadar
edilmiş Aslında hasta mı
[Müzik]
16'da kavramından rakamlar biraz ayıp
üzüm şu anda bile 500 Gülümser
görüşmüyoruz en az 5 kapı bağlı olsa
diye sattılar yuvarlak hesap aç
[Müzik]
o insan varlıklar bedava bitti Bir tane
daha var yaşam bunları engelli yaşamlar
değilmiş izler çok ortada kaldım da var
Biz baştan gidiyoruz bak Salı günü
oluyor ve aklımıza Şu aşağıda görmüyor
1990-2000 17 kırmızıyla görülen yapmış
Allah onu vuracağım herhalde o
[Müzik]
tek başına yaşıyor şimdi sonrası 20 13
milyon yıllık ev yok aslında o
bu kanser Mesela
nasıl
122 alıp yazdım asıl
21006 da biriyim kavrama ulaşmış
yenilebilir bilgi tabi
[Müzik]
insanlar
azaldıkça artı dünyada aslında ha
Neredesin yüzden
özellikle Çin gibi
gibi Uzakdoğu gibi her
defa ülkelerde salgın periyodu geçtiğini
ve bir mavi artı bir maliyetle birlikte
elimize para koymuştuk yavaştı 104 ne
bakıp sağlıklı hizmet etmeye çalışanlar
da cinsiyet eşitsizliğine
bilenler bayağı şu an kesimlere önce
vazgeç A101 işsizliğin Vallahi beyler
bayanlar düşmemiştir olmuş mu
[Müzik]
O bir saat sigortası çalışacağım ve para
elde etmek için geçirmek için yaşamak
için çalışmak çalışmak
[Müzik]
karşı karşıya kalma ihtimali var
Ya hayır bir şey var ya oldu ilişkin
rapor bu çünkü hem iş kaynakları kalınca
kişi var mıyız azalmış olay kayıt içine
aldım serverimiz değil mi az aldım
hakkında ticaret hacmi yüzden 327 20
programı kapattığınızda azalma meydana
geldi
almamışız galiba bunları yiyeceklere
şehitleri nüfus Allah'ın vermiş olabilir
mi
[Müzik]
Çok mersi inşallah
Çünkü o
[Müzik]
o kadar olan hakkınızı
75120 civarı farklı akbuğday oldu Üstüne
aynı Paşa sağlıklı devam etmiş para
bilirsin da farklı gayet 600. yakın
yerdir ve da görmek zor değil mi
[Müzik]
bu
hikaye
şuraya giriyorum bu şekilde yavaş yavaş
dönecek bağladık topu kesiğine
kaybolacak mantığıyla bakmak lazım işte
şu bağışlar İnşallah toplumdaki yerdir
bu üst geçirecek aynı zamanda içeceğim
her zaman içerisinde bunu aynı ve benzer
zamanmış geçip kanınıza artık olmuştur
ya da
olabilir
herkes aynı anda alıp bir geçirerek
hastaneye yakışıyor bölüm 1
[Müzik]
de olmayabilir de karşılığını günlerde
düşüyor bazı ülkelerde satın alıyor
tekrar tekrar dalgalarında
bu
zaman
tek şey oluşur
O çok kısaca program oluşur başlıyorum
eyle 160 larda aşağıdaki geldi ama
maviye geldi arkası var ya
yapıyoruz a
[Müzik]
zty sağlık analizleri yok Allah Allah ya
Bakın tekrar halinde devam edecek 1327
frekans ediyorum burada
bir
başına
ölümden
almaya
İsrail e
[Müzik]
ne hale Gelecek olursak şu anda yüksek
şarkı
acele ediyoruz
[Müzik]
giderken de
Ne yaptınız aşkım
[Müzik]
145 çıkıyor yaklaşık
yani binler şu anda 19'a ilişkiye
edindiğimiz tecrübeleri dışında genel
anlamda çok bilinmedik çok olan düşürdük
diyenler arz etmeye başlar
yavaş yavaş mı
[Müzik]
bu
konuşma nasıl yer var yani var Burada
hepimiz yaşıyoruz daha görürsün diye
işte burası
farklı
olabilir mi
[Müzik]
bu Merhaba baktığımızda helal et sanki
birimler sarmal görüşme ki gerekiyor
Aslında meleğin şu an önce yine öyle
değil Hemen verirsin şöyle hastaneye
yatırıldı da şu anda bilinen ortak
dediler bitkiler görüşelim oldu ya çok
az yakan bir adam
oldum gördün mü
[Müzik]
Ben
sana gerek uygulamaya ücretsiz sinema da
aynı aşk bu içerisinde orta yaprak
başlarda karşınıza her şey projeyi
karşılaşılmış şu
anda
olabilir
diyorsunuz belki
olacak Yakın zamanda o
[Müzik]
sen niye hiç mesaj geldi
aldı yapacağım hiçbir şey aslında
paylaştık mı pek Salih gelmemesi lazım
şimdi salgınlar hastalık anlamında
sadece salgı ile ilgili saat alalım
verelim değil
öğrenci olmalı
[Müzik]
Evet
şu anda ya şu anda belki ondan dolayı
[Müzik]
77 hala eşleşmiyor hiç bulaşmamış alsın
bulaşmamış yastığı var burada buna
karşılık bizim için Önümüzdeki zaman
içerisinde gibi
başladı
Bu
hastalık anlamı ne
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
abone ol